Karina Buen día para usted y este
acercamiento entre ambos países se dio
Gracias al apoyo de España al plan de
autonomía que propone Marruecos o para
el Sáhara occidental un cambio de
postura histórico de Madrid que le puede
salir caro
Sí es que el presidente del gobierno
marroquíes dejó bien claro ayer durante
un foro económico que daba inicio a esta
reunión de alto nivel que ha sido la
única razón este viraje en cuanto al
Sahara occidental se refiere del
gobierno español La única razón por la
que se ha podido llevar a cabo esta
reunión de alto nivel un cambio de
postura que cambiaba 40 años de política
internacional Este cambio de postura
como digo le ha costado al presidente
del gobierno Pedro Sánchez varias
disputas en el seno de su gobierno de
coalición Y es que de los 12 ministros
que le acompañan en este viaje ninguno
es del grupo unidas podemos que son
férreos detractores del plan que propone
Marruecos como solución para El Sahara
occidental además esta decisión del
gobierno español también ha hecho que
empeoren las relaciones entre España y
Argelia país clave en temas energéticos
puesto que es el principal proveedor de
gas España este país en cuanto conoció
la decisión de cambio de postura sobre
Sahara occidental de Madrid llamó a
consultas en marzo de 2022 a su
embajador un diplomático que no ha
retornado y mientras que Marruecos y
España se acercan Marruecos también
sufre el precio y es que la Unión
Europea cada vez se aleja más de este
país después de los escándalos del
qatargate y también de la resolución del
parlamento europeo para pedir más
libertad de prensa ahora mismo los
presidentes del gobierno están en una
sesión plenaria aquí en la sede del
Ministerio de asuntos exteriores donde
se firmarán esos más de 20 acuerdos Así
que el precio final que tendrán que
pagar ambos países se verá en unos meses
cuando estos acuerdos estén en marcha